yeah yeah at the University of public
foreign
looking forward to your talk thank you
Monica
so uh basically
um
in the last two days uh David Aaron
and sohil all three of them gave great
talks related to Dynamic matching so my
talk was also supposed to be on Dynamic
matching and then I thought that there
will be too much of dynamic matching in
one Workshop
so I changed it to Dynamic packing
covering LP
which is basically generalization of
dynamic matching
so uh this is Joint work with tajapal
and my student Peter
let me start with the introduction
so uh
I'll just start with a brief story about
Richard Feynman I don't know if the
story is historically accurate but
that's besides the point
so uh what was feynman's favorite method
for problem solving
it goes like this it consists of three
steps
step one write down the problem step two
think very hard and then step three
write down the answer
now this seems very generic
if we just ask for a specific context
let's say
for designing
static approximation algorithms for
computational problems what would be a
more specific version of this method
well it so happens that for a
non-trivial fraction of approximation
algorithms question
it would go like this step one write
down a suitable LP relaxation
step two think very hard
I'll say three write down a good
rounding scheme
now uh
as you can see if you just look up any
standard textbook on approximation
algorithms there will be several
chapters just devoted to this framework
for those
there are examples of this so for
instance uh yesterday David stock was on
this topic but most of these Frameworks
until now has been mostly applied for
dynamic matching and set cover
and if we ask why why is it that there
are relatively fewer instances of
dynamic rounding schemes
I think one answer would be that it
brings in new kinds of challenges
so if we now look at time complexity in
the standard approximation algorithms
literature
for step one
solving a suitable LP relaxation and
step 3 Implement a good rounding scheme
we are just happy with polynomial
running times
a weapon for most dynamic problems would
ideally like to get poly logarithmic
time for both these two steps
and this is a new challenge that we need
to deal with
and in both these two settings for step
two you have as much time as you want
okay
so uh what are our contributions
our main contribution is for a large
class of LPS packing covering LPS
we resolve the complexity of maintaining
approximate solutions to them in the
dynamic setting
and as you might know bipartite matching
and set covers are special cases of
packing covering LPS but there are many
other
instances that are kept many other
problems that are captured by packing
covering LPS
and at a high level it just says that
we are reducing the question of solving
Dynamic packing covering problems to the
question of Designing good rounding
schemes because we can maintain the
fractional Solutions first
and
basically we initiate a systematic study
of the multiplicative weights update
method in the dynamic setting
okay
so what are our main results
let me precisely Define packing covering
LPS first
so after doing some very standard
scaling which I will just ignore
the problem looks like this we are given
a constraint Matrix C uh all the entries
in this Matrix are non-negative
and the covering LP problem asks us
to find a vector X
whose L1 Norm is just one so sum of all
the coordinates of X is 1 and it
satisfies these covering constraints
that c times x is at least one
and for the Dual packing LP we want to
find a vector y such that c transpose
times y is at most 1 and again the sum
of the coordinates of Y is equal to 1.
now in this talk I will be mostly
focused on Epsilon approximate Solutions
and by that I just mean
for recovering LP just find a vector X
which basically satisfies this covering
constraints up to a multiplicative
factor of 1 minus Epsilon and similarly
for packing LPS find a vector Y which
satisfies this packing constraints up to
a multiplicative factor of 1 plus
Epsilon
now what is the dynamic packing covering
LP problem foreign
setting
you can naturally ask that an update is
basically changing the value of some
entry in this constraint Matrix
and what will be partially Dynamic
settings
you can think of two settings which
mimics sort of like incremental and
decremental algorithms for graph
problems
you can talk about restricting updates
and relaxing updates
and restricting updates basically means
that the feasible region of the lpj
shrinks
relaxing update means that the set of
feasible Solutions only grows
so for instance uh
for covering LP
a restricting update to decrease the
value of some entry in this constraint
Matrix c i j because then if you reduce
the value of c i j here maybe
a solution that was already feasible
before is no longer feasible
[Music]
now I'll just say this you can think of
other natural types of updates in the
partially Dynamic setting like just
insertions of constraints and so on we
can handle those as well but just as a
reference point for Simplicity in the
talk I will just focus primarily on
Entry updates
so with this setup
what are our results
our first main result is that we can
maintain Epsilon approximations to
packing covering LP in partially Dynamic
setting
in amortized poly login update time
complement this
so we obtain this using multiplicative
weight updates
and we complement this
with a
strong lower bound conditional lower
bound based on ACTH
which basically says that even getting
poly login approximation is not possible
in better than linear update time in the
fully Dynamic setting so in the fully
Dynamic setting essentially what you can
do is just recompute the solution from
scratch after every update
and the lower bound is a relatively
straightforward reduction
so in the talk I will just primarily
focus on the up and bound this
yes
so you will encode the I guess what
would usually be the objective by the
normalization constraint yeah exactly
and that you can or cannot update like I
mean I guess you can update as I said
okay
that's a good question let me just go
back to the formulation here
let's say in the partially Dynamic
setting
or even in the fully Dynamic setting if
you just look at the objective function
you can say that okay let me just update
one coefficient in this objective
function that you can and that would
still be captured by this framework
but would it have to go in a specific
Direction I guess like up or down yeah
so in the partially Dynamic setting it
will determine whether you will it will
be determined by whether you are
thinking about a covering LP or packing
LP vis-a-vis restricting or relaxing
updates but you can handle all those
updates
okay
good
so uh rest of the talk I'll just be
focusing on this result
so what is the plan
I'll start with a basic algorithm in the
static setting for getting all about
data structures okay just the vanilla
static algorithm
then I'll talk about how to just
intuitively make it Dynamic why it
should be easily dynamizable
then I'll just come back to the static
algorithm and talk about a slight
modification which allows us to
implement this in near linear time and
finally I'll just show how to implement
this in polylog update time in the
partially Dynamic setting
now one other thing I'd say is uh
the basic static algorithm was already
well known in the literature
so uh there are many people in the
audience who have worked very
extensively on multiplicative weight
updates in the past and our basic static
algorithm is essentially let's say got
column and algorithm okay
however I'm just going to give a fully
self-contained presentation because I
think the presentation
still contains some nice insights so for
instance we are giving a with
independent solver for packing covering
LPS and we are analyzing it in a black
box manner by invoking the regret
minimization Bound for the experts
problem and which we could not find
explicitly stated in the literature
before and it's also relatively simple
okay so I'll just start with the basic
static algorithm
so uh for the purpose of these talks
I'll just use this notations so I'll
just think of packing covering LPS as
generalizing set covers and I'll just
visualize the constraint Matrix as just
a bipartite graph so the elements
correspond to dual variables there are M
of them the sets correspond to Primal
variables there are n of them and they
are x 1 to x n
and there is this complete bipartite
graph so the edge between element I and
ZJ has this value c i j
and each of these values are bounded by
0 and Lambda they are at most Lambda
where Lambda is a parameter
okay and when we are looking at a primal
covering LP so what is happening is it's
a covering constraint so the covering
constraint is on the elements so we are
just looking at all the edges incident
on that element
for every such Edge i j its value gets
multiplied by x i j and we are just
saying that the total value of all the
edges incident on this element needs to
be at least 1 minus Epsilon
and similarly when we are looking at the
Dual
packing NP the constraints are on the
sets and these are packing constraints
so you are just saying the sum of the
packing values of the ages incident on
XJ is at most
OnePlus Epsilon so this is how I'll
visualize it
okay
our goal is just this either written an
approximate covering solution or written
an approximate packing solution one of
them that's the problem
good
so what's the basic static algorithm
okay it will consist of T rounds where T
is roughly Lambda Times log n divided by
Epsilon squared
and we will work with weight so we will
keep a weight for every set denoted by
EXT hat initialized to 1 and a weight
for every element denoted by y i hat
initialized to zero
and we will maintain Primal Solutions
and dual Solutions which will just be
the normalized weight so henceforth when
I am talking about the value of the
variable x j this is by definition the
normalized weight of the set XJ and
similarly the value for
the variable y i is just the normalized
weight for element I just to be pedantic
I mean you're dividing by zero good
point
it will not be valid just after the
first round that's true okay
so all the time we are just maintaining
a primal solution whose L1 Norm is one
and a dual solution sorry
yeah a dual solution whose L1 Norm is
one and the Primal solution whose L1
Norm is also one we now just want to
satisfy the constraints approximately
that's the setup
okay
so uh now it runs in t rounds what
happens in a given round
at the start of this round if x our set
cover solution is already approximately
feasible nothing else to do we just
return X and we stop
or it's not feasible that means there
must be some violated covering
constraint for some element I
so I am just highlighting
the edges participating in this
constraint in red okay
and now what it tells us is to satisfy
this we just need to raise the weights
on the corresponding sets
and we do two things we first increase
the weight of the element additively by
one so we are increasing the Dual
weights additively and we will increase
the Primal weights multiplicatively so
for every set x t for every set J what
is this c i j divided by Lambda is just
this coefficient divided by Lambda so
that this quantity becomes between 0 and
1. so if this set has c i j value large
we should raise its weight more and so
on that's it
and now I will just refer to this
operation as whacking this constraint I
because we are as if just trying to
satisfy this constraint so I'll just
call it a whack
and that's the entire algorithm and I'll
just refer to it as guacamole
multiplicative weight updates because
you can just visualize these elements as
being moles and in each round you are
just identifying a mole a constraint
that is violated that you need to work
and once you figure out that ok there
are no many moles no more moles to work
by default you have an approximate
covering solution you return that's the
algorithm and for all J is it from J in
the violated constraints oh here I'm
just visualizing it as a complete Piper
type graph so this c i JS would be zero
if J does not appear in this constraint
yes
okay
now
okay good point I'll just come back to
it later on in the static setting this
one is fine in the dynamic setting you
need to make this one minus Epsilon but
it's like technical reason
yeah
the whole approach requires writing the
explicit
ly very good point it does not work for
implicit LPS because our entire update
times and run times is just in terms of
the number of non-zeros in the
constraint Matrix
and I will just say one other thing that
if you just view what is happening to
the packing LP this step this is
okay
now
how to analyze this
so the first thing to note is
if we return in this part because we
already found an approximately feasible
covering solution it's trivial to say
that ok we have correctly solved our
problem nothing to argue about so the
key Lemma that we want to prove is that
at the if we did not enter this step
then after capital T rounds why
is actually an approximate feasible
solution to the packing LP and if we
have that then we are either always
returning a valid covering solution or a
valid packing solution
just another at some point you mentioned
wit independent yeah
good right now the analysis I'll give
will depend on Lambda but later on there
is an implementation where you can get
rid of it
okay
so now the proof of the key Lemma
here we will just invoke the experts
setting
as follows
we will just assume that each set
corresponds to an expert and we are in
this following
a scenario
there are t rounds
now at the start of each round
we pick an expert according to the
distribution X because X is a
distribution because it has L one Norm
one
and now nature which actually is the
algorithm finds a violated covering
constraint because otherwise that round
would not have run
I
and the payoffs of expert J would just
be given by c i j divided by Lambda so
that these payoffs are now between 0 and
1.
and so we received some expected payoff
what is our expected payoff okay we we
pick expert J with probability XJ we
receive this payoff some over these
things that's our expected payoff
and after this we basically update the
weights on each expert multiplicatively
and you will notice that the way we are
updating these weights c i j divided by
Lambda this is precisely the payoff that
expert J receives so this is precisely
the experts setting okay
now just applying a very well known name
Lemma so what is our objective our
objective is to basically maximize our
payoff
in comparison to the best possible
expert in hindsight so applying a very
well known Lemma we have this inequality
here
even ignoring this equation this symbols
all it is saying is this term is just
the average payoff we get across over T
rounds
this is sort of like our average regret
and all we are saying is that our
average payoff is very close to the
average payoff of Any Given expertise
and there is this multiplicative one
minus Epsilon term here
now what does this tell us
first of all we are setting capital T to
be large enough
precisely so that this average regrade
becomes small
so if we set T to be like this our
average regret just becomes Epsilon over
Lambda and that was the only reason why
we set T to be like this
so after this substitution
this is the new inequality we have
and what I will do now is I'll just
upper bound the average payoff we get
and lower bound the average payoff of
expert J
if you now look at the average payoff we
get what can we say
fix any round I sorry fix any round t
let I be the violated covering
constraint at Round t
so what is our average payoff
just by definition in round T just look
at those highlighted edges that's the
violated covering constraint expert J is
being selected with probability X see so
this T just denotes that we are in round
t
and its payoff is just c i j over Lambda
and we chose a violated covering
constraint in round T that just means
that the sum of these c i j values over
all J
is at most one that covering constraint
was violated so our expected payoff is
at most one over Lambda
so if our payoff in any given round is
at most 1 over Lambda of course our
average payoff over all rounds is still
at most 1 over Lambda
so
now we can just know that our average
payoff is
all over Lambda this great was at most
Epsilon over Lambda so we just add these
two things up the right hand side is
just one plus Epsilon divided by Lambda
okay
now we will just lower bound the average
payoff of Any Given expert J and this
will just tell us that the packing
constraint on the set J is satisfied
approximately this is where this one
plus Epsilon term will come from
okay
so what is the average payoff of expert
J again
fix any down to T let I be the violated
covering constraint in round t
what is the payoff of J in round t
by definition it's just c i of J this
coefficient divided by Lambda
and now we just observe
that this is the reason why we
additively increased the Dual weight y i
by 1 in that round
we observe that this term c i j times
the Dual weight
actually
this increase is exactly equal to c i j
because y i hat we increased additively
by one
in round t the only increase the Y I hat
and no other
weights on other dual elements we only
increased y i hat so this increase
is just the same as
the increase
in the value of the packing constraint
because for all other I primes y i Prime
hat did not increase at all
okay
now
this side this term is just the value of
the packing constraint for J and the
unscaled value with respect to the
weights unnormalized values
now what can we say we initialized these
packing weights to zero
so initially
this packing value was Zero
and after every round
the packing value
increased
by exactly the same amount as the payoff
received by that expert modulo this one
over Lambda term
so at the end of all the rounds the
of expert
gym is just precisely one over Lambda
times the packing value of that
constraint the unscaled packing value
and so the average payoff of expert J is
just this divided by the total number of
rounds
and now what can we say about the total
number of rounds t is just the sum of
the Dual weights
and why is it the case
because in each round after implementing
the round we just increased one of the y
a hat why I hat values by one
so if capital T the number of rounds is
just the total value of all the Dual
weights
of course y i Prime
the actual dual value the normalized
Dual value is just y i Prime hat divided
by T
and if we just look at this expression
it just gives us that this is equal to 1
over Lambda times just precisely
the packing constraint value the left
hand side
plug these two things together
what do we get
so this is the average payoff of expert
J I have just put this thing here
so just look at these two inequalities
this Lambda will just get canceled you
can take this one minus Epsilon on the
other side and you will just see that
the Dual constraint
corresponding to
set J is satisfied
up to a multiplicative one plus Epsilon
Factor
and hence this just implies that at the
end of T rounds Y is an approximately
feasible solution to the packing LP
that's it
and
I'll just say this there is nothing new
in this algorithm but one thing that I
myself find a bit interesting is that as
I said if you look at what is happening
to this y i values that's precisely
algorithm and we are just analyzing it
in a black box manner using this experts
framework
Okay so
this is it
and this is our starting static
algorithm now why does this work
why is it a good candidate to dynamize
now
just to make things specific I am going
to look at the following setting
we have a covering LP that's undergoing
restricting updates
or alternatively you can think of the
Dual packing LP's undergoing relaxing
updates and we just want to maintain an
Epsilon approximate solution
okay here is the main insight
figure behind dynamization
yeah go ahead
what does it mean in the set cover hold
your your
your
deleting elements or reducing the okay
good in the set cover word it just means
let's say we are inserting elements
that's a restricting update in the setup
yeah inserting an email
I think it's not covered yet yeah
so the existing solution might still
might no longer be valid
okay
uh so I thought you're only changing the
constraint Matrix okay good
be like you are removing an element from
a set no uh okay if you think in terms
of constraint Matrix it will be like uh
give me one second
if you think in terms of Entry updates
that would be you are saying okay this
element now no longer belongs to this
set that's a restricting update
and you can also think of a restricting
update in terms of just inserting a new
constraint that also shrinks the
feasible region so both of these are
restricting updates it just is whichever
one you find easier to visualize we can
handle both of them
okay
so that's the setting
now what is the main challenge here
the
multiplicative weights update is
essentially an iterative algorithm
so what it is doing is it's just running
in rounds
just in the static setting and in each
round it's just checking a condition and
the condition here is basically whether
there exists some constraint some
element that is not yet covered
and if this condition holds then you
just whack that constraint satisfy that
constraint and move on to the next round
otherwise if the condition does not hold
that's a cross here with red then you
just return your existing solution
so you keep doing these rounds like this
in the static setting and then at some
point you stop
now these type of iterative algorithms
would
usually be very hard to dynamize why
because what is happening in a round
very much depends on what happened in
the previous round
so if I now just make a small update
maybe in this round you wanted to do
something different and that would have
a huge cascading effect going forward
so that's one issue
now in our case the key Insight is this
these partially Dynamic settings with
the restricting updates are nice in the
sense that after a restricting update
the past decisions that you have made
continue to remain valid
so for instance if you visualize the
restricting update by saying that okay
an element is being inserted that's our
restricting update so there was a
constraint that's now present which was
not present before
and we are currently here so in previous
round so let's say in this round what
happened we just identified a violated
constraint we whacked it that decision
is still valid it's a still valid round
for the current input
so all we need to do is now just move
forward
so okay maybe after insertation of a new
constraint we are now in this
case here so we just whack that
constraint
and keep working for a few more rounds
and then we get stopped and we stop here
and eventually when we reach round T we
can just output the Dual packing
solution
so that's the high level insight as to
why it works in the partially
just one brief clarification the like
whacking that you you do it doesn't in
one step make sure that the constraints
you might need to do multiple ways okay
and actually clubbing together these wax
is how you get a fast static
implementation okay
so now let me just give you precisely
what the dynamic algorithm would look
like in this basic template
and let's just assume that initially
let's say for the set cover instance
there were no elements so ah all these
constraints were trivially satisfied
after our initialization step where we
initialize the weight of every set to 1
and weight of every element to zero
so
this is pre-processing and at this time
we are in round zero
now at some point in time
a restricting update comes what might
happen maybe there is some new
constraint that is violated which was
not violated before
so we will just happily go along and
just implement the next round so in the
next round we are just supposed to
increment to the Dual weight by one
did this we multiplicatively update the
weights of the
sets
then a
we have reached this threshold capital T
then we have gone on for two long
iterations too many iterations so we
will just claim that the Dual solution
we have is a feasible packing solution
so we will just stop doing any
computation we will just output this Y
at all future time steps as a feasible
packing solution
and now under restricting updates if Y
is a feasible packing solution now it
remains a feasible packing solution at
all future time steps
that's it so it's as if you are just
taking the static algorithm and just
seamlessly extending it to the dynamic
setting
and you can go through the math
and the key Lemma that we proved still
works in this
okay
in the prison
okay so uh
now
as it was pointed out very clearly that
right now we are saying that run this
for Lambda login round even in the
static setting this is not very
efficient because blender might be
polynomial we want a near linear time
implementation to begin within the
static City
so here is a standard way of making it
near linear time
we are now back in the static setting
so if you look at what this algorithm is
doing
if you look at what this algorithm is
doing what is the inefficient part
if you just look at one whacking step
this part is actually very fast
all we are saying is okay look at one
particular constraint I that is violated
provided we manage to find that
constraint quickly
then you just look at all the sets that
participate in that constraint you are
just multiplying the weights of those
sets and this takes time proportional to
just the number of non-zero coefficients
in that constraint this is fast enough
for us
so whacking a single constraint can be
done fast the problem is number of
rounds is too large we can't afford
Lambda login many rounds
so how to make this fast ideally we'd
like to say something like that this
that and this algorithm would whack
every constraint only polylog many times
then we will be happy
foreign
so what we do we just slightly modify
this algorithm
yeah so um wise enough that
the moment that's not covered by any
can you can you have a lot of non-zeroes
in that case good point when I say
number of non-zeros it's a partially
Dynamic setting so it's look at the
final state of the constraint Matrix the
number of non-zeros you have at that
time and our total update time will be
with respect to that
the number of rows because earlier you
said you're adding a an element oh okay
so if your question is that okay it is
fitting update just inserts a new
constraint which maybe has thousand many
non-zero coefficients then of course the
time should be proportional to the
number of non-zero coefficients you
inserted you can't expect to have
polynoxide yes okay
good so ideally would like to say
something like this but it's too good to
be true but there is a easy fix
so the easy fix is this we'll just run
this algorithm in phases
and we will just use the fact that these
weights
that these weights are monotonically
increasing so the weights on the sets
are increasing monotonically so we
initiate a new phase
whenever the sum of the weights on the
sets increases by a multiplicative one
plus Epsilon Factor
and now this is an easy claim to prove I
will just keep this proof because of
lack of time
we can show that the total weights on
the sets will remain polynomially
bounded
and once you have this it just
immediately implies that the number of
phases would just be login
because you are initiating a phase only
when this total weight increases by one
plus Epsilon factor and initially the
total weight was just n
now what we do in one phase
let capital W denote the total weights
of the sets at the start of the phase
this will remain fixed capital W the
value of capital W remains fixed
and throughout the phase I will just
pretend that the actual value of the
variable XJ is just its weight divided
by capital W not the actual sum of total
weights
and this is fine because capital W is at
most a multiplicative 1 plus Epsilon
Factor off from the sum of total weights
so nothing should change as far as
approximation guarantee is concerned
and now in this phase what we are doing
is we are just looping through all the
constraints one at a time
and whenever we reach constraint I we
just keep whacking it until it gets
satisfied that's how we club together
all the ways
and now here is the crucial observation
for the rest of the phase once we are
done with this this constraint will
remain satisfied
why because capital W did not change
and x j hat only increases So within the
phase the value of x j can only go up
so if right now this constraint is
satisfied it's a covering constraints
let's look at this constraint it's
satisfied right now in future XJ values
can only go up so this covering
constraint will continue to remain
satisfied
and now this step keep working eye until
it gets satisfied can be done in real
linear time in the size of the
constraint
and that why because you first guess the
number of times you need to work this
constraint to satisfy this and this is a
simple binary search
and once you have figured out this value
you just go ahead and do this for every
variable appearing in this constraint
so one iteration of these four Loops
just takes me a linear time in the size
of the constraint concerned constraint
and you are going to consider a
constraint at most once during this for
Loop so the time taken to implement a
phase is just near linear in the number
of non-zero entries in the entire
constraint Matrix
and there are only log in many phases so
the total time overall phases is also
low
so this is how you implement it in near
linear time
and now you go ahead and say that okay
what happens in the dynamic setting okay
you need to prove this claim which I
will skip
and
now you ask what happens in the dynamic
setting
you can just come up with a very natural
generalization of the scheme I presented
right now that works but there is one
additional challenge
the challenge just is I'll just point
out the challenge and skip the proof as
to how we overcome this challenge
so the dynamic variant of this scheme
would be that we are in the current
phase a restricting update arrives we
identify this constraint that is
violated keep working I until it gets
satisfied fine
but in the static setting the analysis
crucially hinged on the fact that this
constraint will remain satisfied
throughout the rest of the phase this is
no longer too true in the dynamic
setting because maybe you act this
constraint sufficiently to satisfy it in
future there might be one other
restricting update which is basically
reducing the value of some cij and it
becomes violated again
so that's a problem that we need to
address
with some extra work
uh it no longer holds under restricting
updates
so what we say is let's just look at
this operation keep working I until it
gets satisfied I'll just call this
operation enforcing a constraint I
enforcement of constraint type with some
extra work we can prove this key Lemma
that in the dynamic setting a given
constraint I would get enforced at most
poly log times this is slightly
non-trivial but it holds
and
now I skip the proof of the key Lemma
and that's it
so now to conclude
I'll just conclude with I think two main
open questions
one is uh we could extend our framework
to mixed packing covering LPS however
only under relaxing updates
and for technical reasons we could not
solve mixed packing covering LPS under
restricting updates
and there is every reason to believe
that such an algorithm might exist
that's one open question
and the second thing is uh this is the
question that I started with that in
static approximation algorithms there
are so many instances where you first
solve it and relaxation and then round
it
now that we know how to solve packing
covering LPS
can we do this apply this framework for
other Dynamic problems and here one
other challenge we might need to
overcome is what only pointed out that
we are just assuming explicit LPS so in
many natural problems the lp might have
exponentially many constraints and we
need to deal with that
so that's it thank you
[Applause]
fully dynamic
yeah
um
so the lower Bound for the fully Dynamic
for fully Dynamic I just go there
yeah
so what kind of updates does it assume
it does it assume
um element insertions and deletions or
entry yeah it's the weakest form of
update you can assume so it's basically
changing one entry of the constraint
Matrix and does it also imply anything
for set cover no it doesn't imply
anything okay
yes
what other direction for generalization
is going Beyond LPS and uh so one I
don't know if there's work on this but
um can one dynamically uh maintain a
solution to Max cut for example which
uses a semi-definite program that's an
excellent question I I don't know but I
I do agree that's an excellent openness
how the speed up of your algorithm the
part where like binary search for the
the number of times in whack-a-mole
compared to like with independent model
weight update
so
if
if you just look at the static algorithm
we have uh okay I shouldn't say we have
this was known in the literature already
when we go from the static to Dynamic
setting we don't incur any extra Epsilon
Factor loss
so uh I don't know if there is any
alternate variant of the static
algorithm which incurs
less Epsilon Factor loss that I don't
know so I thought I thought with
independent modeling also gives you like
whatever Epsilon squared right one over
one over one squared oh so
here's the thing let me just point this
thing out
when I wrote this thing 1 over Epsilon
cubed
if you just look at this problem
precisely in this slide for this our
amortized update time is 1 over Epsilon
squared
now why I'm writing 1 over Epsilon cubed
here because when you just throw in an
objective function in the partially
Dynamic setting you need to make guesses
on the objective function that incurs an
extra Epsilon Factor
so there is a linear over Epsilon
packing algorithms yeah right that's
true I don't know how to dynamize it
one quick question so can we hope for
the amortization of the bottom the lower
bound here uh says that even worst case
update time is not possible even like a
week at a laser number one like the end
partially Dynamic updates and basically
this lower bound is not that difficult
once you just identify the starting
conjecture to reduce it from and this is
actually quite standard in Dynamic
algorithms that you get a fully Dynamic
lower an amortized lower Bound in the
fully Dynamic world and simultaneously
that gives you a worst case lower Bound
in the partially Dynamic world and
that's precisely What's Happening Here
thank you
are there other questions in the
comments
maybe I have one more question I think
you have applications in in your paper
right and I would be interested in like
you know maybe just repeat the
applications I would also be interested
in can you reconstruct any known results
maybe not you know how to up to like the
best known bound but okay morally so on
this note I'll just say we can
reconstruct what Arun presented in the
morning because let's say decremental
matching even weighted matching if you
ignore exact poly log n dependencies or
exact one over Epsilon dependencies
decremental matching is a case of uh
maintaining impacting LP under
restricting updates
so now I actually don't have a very good
intuition myself
as to
is this multiplicative weight update
thing doing the same thing as congestion
balancing or not
I don't know
but yeah so you can get decremental
matching using money
okay
okay then there's a break now let's
thank sign again and we meet again at 3
15.
thank you